since the dawn of time we've been
obsessed with the process of aging
or rather how we can stop it
from fables of the fountain of youth to
the pictures of dorian gray
man has dreamed of a world where the
slow passage of time can be brought to a
halt
we mostly think it's a myth right but
does young blood hold the secret to the
fountain of youth
there's an entire field of research
dedicated to addressing the biology of
aging it's called geroscience
[Music]
and one spanish pharmaceutical firm
might have actually stumbled upon the
answer we've all been waiting for grifos
was founded by tony wisco
a neuroscientist from stanford
university whose research revealed that
blood from young mice could potentially
have restorative effects for elderly
mice if they received the blood via
transfusion but what if there was
something to it what if there was
something to this fountain of youth
one particular study saw elderly mice
hooked up to the blood supply of younger
rodents essentially meaning that the two
shared the same circulatory system and
researchers were baffled at their
findings the older mice could heal
wounds faster and repair small tears in
their muscles quicker
however it was the younger mice who
suffered the consequences as their own
ability to heal wounds dramatically
decreased
while the old mice grew more energetic
the younger mice suddenly behaved as if
they were middle aged
the results generated worldwide
headlines and also someone wanted
attention from a man who offered to
provide all the blood whiskering might
need for such an experiment with claims
he could obtain it from human children
of any age alongside this floods of
pleas from alzheimer's patients and
their loved ones inquiring about human
trials
back in 2016 a startup company called
ambrosia started offering young blood
transfusions for eight
reports claim around 600 people signed
up to the dracula-esque enterprise
regular transfusions of the blood of a
younger physically fit donor can
significantly [ __ ] the aging process
the company closed down in 2019 amid
fears from the u.s food and drug
administration although a 2020 report in
the guardian claimed it since got back
up and running
now even if the technology is totally
harmless it does appear as though the
private sphere and the wealthy will be
the first and possibly the only people
to reap the rewards
what are the consequences of that well
billionaires will live forever while the
rest of us might just live
a little bit less
[Music]
you